my name is John Gray they call me the
dishwasher our co-founder ghetto gastro
a bronx based collective that works at
the intersection of food design and art
we create experiences that challenge
people's perceptions of the Bronx the
place that I call home it's a funny
thing I just touched down in Vancouver
from Paris a few days ago we took over
the place Vaughn dome with the Bronx
browser I read we we share read it's
wild because in Paris they have this
saying
LeBron's which means something is in
disarray or a problem that's the
platform don't you shut it down one time
this lingo came into play when the Bronx
was burning in movies like the Warriors
and for Apache still making an
impression some may disagree but I
believe the Bronx was designed to fail
the power broker was a joker Robert
Moses instead the part in the Red Sea he
parted the Bronx with a six-lane Highway
and Red Line my community my
great-grandparents had a home on
featherbed Lane and contrary to the name
they couldn't get a good night's rest
due to the constant blasting and
drilling that was necessary to build the
Cross Bronx Expressway
a block away I considered these policy
decisions design crimes
being a Brazilian people that we are
uptown out of the systematic oppression
hip-hop culture rose from the rubble in
the ashes like a phoenix hip hop is now
a trillion dollar industry but this
economic activity doesn't make it back
to the Bronx or communities like it
let's take it back to 1986 I was born in
the heart of the AIDS crisis the crack
epidemic and the war on drugs the only
thing that should go down from
Reaganomics was get on a mix pain prison
and poverty I was raised by brilliant
beautiful and accomplished black women
even so my pops wasn't in the picture
and I couldn't resist the allure of the
streets like biggie said you either
slinging crack rock or you got a wicked
jump shot don't get it twisted my jumper
was wet my was black but when I
turned 15 I started selling weed I
didn't finish high school the New York
Board of Education banned me from all of
those but I did graduates are selling
cocaine when I turn 18 I did well that
was until I got jammed up caught a case
when I was 20 I was facing 10 years I
posted bail signed up at the Fashion
Institute I applied the skills that I
learned in the streets to start my own
fashion brand my lawyer Pete my ambition
so he suggested that the judge grant me
a suspended sentence for once in my life
a suspension was a good thing
over the course of two years and many
court dates my case got dismissed both
of my brothers have done jail time so
escaping the clutches of the prison
industrial system didn't seem realistic
to me right now one of my brothers is
facing 20 years my mother put in great
effort and taking me out to eat making
sure we visited museums and traveled
abroad basically exposing me to as much
kosher as she could I remembered how as
a kid I used to take over the dinner
table and order food for everybody
breaking bread has always allowed me to
break the mold and connect with people
me and my homie les we grew up on the
same block in the Bronx
two Street dudes he happened to be a
chef we always discussed the possibility
of doing something in the food game for
the benefit of our neighborhood les had
just won the Food Show chopped our homey
Malcolm was gearing up to run a pastry
kitchen at Noma
yeah world's best Noma in Copenhagen you
know the vibes my man P had just
finished training and Eataly Milano to
be exact we decided the world needed
some Bronx seasoning on it so he mobbed
up and foam ghetto gastro
[Applause]
while I'm aware our name makes a lot of
people uncomfortable for us ghetto means
home similar to the way someone in
Mumbai or Nairobi might use the word
slum it's to locate our people and to
indict the systems of neglect that
created these conditions so what is
ghetto gastro ultimately it's a movement
in the philosophy we view the work we do
as gastro diplomacy using food and
finesse to open borders and connect
culture last year in Tokyo we did a
Caribbean paddy we do jerk Wagyu beef
she'll kombu we remix the Bronx classic
with the Japanese elements and for
Kwanzaa we had to pay homage to our
Puerto Ricans and we did a coconut
charcoal cognac coquito Dee Malone this
here is our black power waffle with some
gold leaf syrup make sure you don't slip
on the drip here we got the 36 Brix
plant-based Vlado Strawberry Fields you
know the del compressed watermelon basil
seeds a little bit of strawberries up
there back to the Bronx bras Irene you
know we had to hit him in the head with
that caviar and cornbread
we also practice do-rag diplomacy
because we don't edit who we are when we
do our thing
due to our appearance we often get
mistaken for rappers athletes it
happened here last year at Ted this dude
ran down on me and asked me when I was
going to perform how about now so you
see we've been bringing the Bronx to the
world but now we focus on bringing the
world to the Bronx we just opened our
spot and idea kitchen will be making
design products create content
[Music]
and host community events the intention
is to build financial capital and
creative capital in our hood we're also
collaborating with world-renowned Chef
Massimo Mathura
on a repertory Oh in the Bronx a
repertory of the design focused soup
kitchen and community center see the
vibes the recent outpouring of grief
about the murder of rapper and
entrepreneur and nipsey hussle is
largely due to the fact that he decided
to stay and evolve in place rather than
leave his hood after his death some may
see this decision is foolish but I'm
making that same decision every day to
live in the Bronx to create in the Bronx
to invest in the Bronx
at ghetto gastro we don't run from the
word ghetto and we don't run from D
ghetto because at the end of the day
ghetto gas was about showing you what we
already know the hood is good thank you
[Applause]